heading down the slipway on the somerset
coast
it doesn't take too much digging to
uncover the plastic
lots of little bits of plastic today on
portis head beach the turn the tide
volunteers meet fortnightly
and their bags are always full this is a
plastic jerry can obviously it's been
quite weathered and battered by
um the sea but there will be lots of
micro plastics that would have come off
this
they've been collecting plastic here for
the last two and a half years
the problem will always exist in some
format we've seen it get gradually worse
um in the last few years but equally
we're doing a lot more beach cleans so
we're finding that
we're actually picking up a lot more
from the tide but the tide keeps
bringing him more and more so the
problem is almost endless and at times
you feel
just like helpless we are all by now
aware of the plastic crisis but a new
study has predicted just how much worse
it's going to get scientists from the
university of leeds and 17
other experts around the world have
developed a new digital model to track
the stock and movement of plastic around
the globe
the bristol waste company processes our
plastic rubbish and it ends up
in half a ton blocks like these now the
report says that between
2016 and 2040 nearly a
billion tons of plastic will be
discarded into the environment
that's about 2 billion of these blocks
just
dumped in 2040 alone it says 133 million
tons of plastic we burnt
77 million tons will end up in the land
and around
29 million tons could go out to sea
the report predicts that in 20 years
time around
half the world's population won't get
their rubbish collected
and processed our research confirms
that the most impactful single
intervention
is to having people's waste collected
across the global south
of course as we said we need to combine
these within a suite
of measures going upstream on how much
plastic we produce and consume
and improving collection and recycling
as well
the golf tee or the bottom of the golf
tee is here to make the situation worse
these grim
predictions already factor in
governments sticking to their current
commitments
on reducing waste that means we all need
to do
much more if we're to stop the tide of
plastic pollution
damn whitehead sky news